يتوجه الناخبون في الولايات المتحده خلال
ساعات الى صناديق الاقتراع للادلاء
باصواتهم في الانتخابات النصفيه يتنافس
الحزبان الجمهوري والديمقراطيه على جميع
مقاعد مجلس النواب البالغي عددها
435 مقعدا
ويتنافسون كذلك على 35 مقعدا من مقعد مجلس
الشيوخ البالغ عددها 100 مقعد كما يتنافس
الحزبان على سته وثلاثين منصبا من مناصبه
حكام الولايات الخمسين تشير ارقامه
الاستطلاعات الى ان الجمهوريين يعتبرون او
يعتبرون الاوفر حبا في الفوز في اغلبيه في
مجلس النواب بينما يتوقع ان تكون المنافسه
شديده بين الحزبين للفوز باغلبيه طفيفه في
مجلس الشيوخ ويسيطر الديمقراطيون حاليا
على المجلسا
تدعو اخر استطلاعات الخاصه بمجلس الشيوخ
سته ولايات في خانه الولايات المتارجحه
بالنظر لتقارب مرشحي الحزبين فيها هذه
الولايات هي جورجيا بن سلفينيا نيفادا
اريزونا وسكانسن واني هامشر واذا حصل
الجمهوريون على ثلاثه منها فيرجح فوزهم
بالاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
اما في مجلس النواب التنافس بين الحزبين
في نحو 34 مقعدا متارجحا وتشير استطلاعات
الراي الى تفوق محتمل للحزب الجمهوري
والفوز بما بين 10 و20 مقعدا ما يكفي
لحصول الحزب الجمهوري على الاغلبيه
ومن واشنطن معنى مراسلنا محمد العلمي محمد
اهلا بك من جديد اذا بايدي وترامب
يتبادلان الاتهامات
وروسيا تعترف او على الاقل رئيس شركه بانر
بانه تدخل في الانتخابات واستقطاب حاد ما
الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه وكيف يمكن وصف
الاجواء في واشنطن ونحن فقط من بدايه
الانتخابات
مدى الاحتقان والظروف التي تمر بهذه
الانتخابات بالنسبه للتدخل الروسي همم
المزعوم على اللقاء حتى الان همم لم همم
يتوقف فقط عن همم اقرار همم احد المقربين
من الرئيس الروسي فقط بل ايضا جاء امس في
تقرير المطول
الى
ابحاث قامت بها همم
مؤسسات تعنى بالعالم الصيبراني وتوصلت الى
ان مجموعه من الحسابات الوهميه التي كانت
ناشطه في انتخابات عام 2020
عاده همم الى الحركه والى النشاط همم في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وين اختار هذه
المره مواقع حديثه وصغيره بالمقارنه مع
كبريات المواقع كفيسبوك وتويتر وغيرها وان
اصحاب هذه الحسابات
يتنكرون بشخصيات يمينيه متطرفه تحاول
برسائلها تحقيق ثلاث اهداف على ما يبدو
على ما خلصت عيده
الانقسام والكراهيه بين افراد المجتمع
الامريكي وايضا تشكيك الامريكيين همم في
اساليب الديمقراطيه من عمليه انتخاب الى
التشكيك في همم العمليات الفرز وهمم
الادعاء بانه يتم التلاعب بها وايضا
العنصر الثالث وهذا هو الذي عزز الشكوك
بانه روسيا وراء هذه الحمله تحديدا هي
التقليل من دعم العامه الامريكي
لدعم امريكا همم اوكرانيا في حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا
ويبدو ان هذه الحمله بدات تؤذي اكلها
بالفعل لان بعض المرشحين الجمهوريين بداوا
يرددون بالفعل بعد الشعارات همم والجمل
حتى التي جاءت في مثل هذه المواقع الوهميه
والتي
فيه بان او ترمي الى اقناع الى عامل
امريكي بان هذه الاموال طائله همم من
اموال دفع الضرائب الامريكيين التي تذهب
الى اوكرانيه همم يمكن
الاستفاده بها اكثر اذا عدنا بالفعل الى
همم سيناريوهات التي عايشينها في
الانتخابات 2016
وعلى الرغم من لجوء هؤلاء الى
صغيره وحديثه اا لكن وجد خطاب اهلها او
اصحابها اا ارضيه خصبه في الجو المشحون
المنقسم لدى همم الامريكيين
وبدات بالفعل هذه الشعارات همم
توظف في الحمله الانتخابيه في حمله
انتخابيه تغز عليها عموما كما سمعنا قبل
قليل محاوله الديمقراطيين رفع الوعي
والخوف
بالخوف على الديمقراطيه نفسها همم في وجه
همم مجموعه كبيره من اليمنيين المتشددين
الذين تقدموا مرشحين وما زالوا يشكيكون
حتى في نتيجه الانتخابات الرئاسيه الماضيه
وحتى في شرعيات رئيس
بينما ركز الجمهوريون على قضايا الجيب من
التضخم الى غلاء الاسعار الى الهجره وهذا
موضوع
همم يحمس كثيرا القواعد التقليديه للحزب
الجمهوري ويبدو ان الناخبه الامريكيه على
الرغم من الاستطلاعات الراي العام شوشير
الى خوف الاغلبيه الساحقه على مستقبل
الديمقراطيه وان انتخاب مثل بعض المتطرفين
قد يهدد مستقبل ديموغرافيه الامريكيه لكن
همم استطاعات الراي العام تشير ايضا الى
ان اغلبيه نقيب الامريكيين يفضلون قضايا
الرجيم وقضايا الاقتص